Oh
this is problem number two the first
real problem I tried to find some nice
combinations that's suitable for for
this kind of exercise in my recent games
but it's not easy and the ones I could
think of I couldn't remember the
solution myself so instead there's
there's a lot of there were a lot of
nice combinations in my games from 10
years ago or so and this is one of them
a black like to play like is a pawn up
but the knight is stranded so we need to
find a radical solution
you
at an early age I as many others learned
that the first thing you should examine
in a position is possible captures and
possible checks and for black here there
are not many captures available and the
only capture is possible lose a piece
and once we start examining the checks
we find really only two checks one of
them just drops a night but the other
one is much better now as soon soon as
we discover this move we know that it's
the right solution since then we see
that when white takes the Queen which is
forced we have rook over here with
checkmate because the knight core is the
only escape square